I was asked what am I going to do now
that I've transitioned Bridgewater
um and and how's it what's the new
activity for Ray Dalia what's he going
to do
um first of all what a journey it's been
47 years it's been fantastic and I'm so
excited to have passed it on to others
and now it's theirs and and so one of
the things I'm going to do is be a
mentor there in other words help them uh
to be able to help this Chief investment
officers help the management to the
extent that they want that I'm going to
be a mentor but I've now been able to
free up my time and free up my worries
about uh the issues so I can have more
time to devote to things that I really
love and so what are those things well
um interacting with the world trying to
understand how the world Works having
principles and operating with that
particularly in the investment in
macroeconomic area is a very exciting
area for me and I started to do that
when I was 12. I'll do it to a lie die
I'll have that passion so I'm going to
continue to do that that kind of
research and communicate I've changed
who I'm speaking with before I would
deal with internal Bridgewater employees
and also Bridgewater clients now I want
to help everybody I want to pass it
along I'm here communicating with you
for that reason so I'm that's what my
objective is to pass along and to have
this kind of broader constituency that
I'm being able to be helpful to
um number three
um is I have uh an opportunity and I
continue to help policy makers around
the world deal with their particular
issues that's a source of great
satisfaction uh number four and by the
way it's not in this particular order is
I have a passion for uh ocean
exploration and also different kinds of
philanthropies and I'm going to pursue
those areas and then of course I don't
know maybe it's my highest priority it's
right up there is spending quality time
with my family so I've got a lot of
exciting things to do in various
Dimensions that I'm savoring life and
I'm savoring this transition so that'll
be the new gray dalio and I hope we'll
see more of each other